[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم افيده باسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى نتابع هذه الصور المباشره من
القدس بعد اجتماع لحكومه نتنياهو بنفق
اسفل الحائط الغربي بالمسجد الاقصى اكد
فيه على استكمال معركه توحيد القدس
من واشنطن وتحديدا من البيت الابيض تاتينا
هذه الصور المباشره حيث ينتظر اي ينعقد
الليله لقاء بين المتفاوضين من
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين قبل اقل من
اسبوعين على موعد الاول من يونيو حذرا
الذي حذرت في وزاره الخزانه من ان الحكومه
الاتحاديه قد تكون غير قادره على سداد
جميع ديونها بحلوله والى العاصمه
اليونانيه اثينا وتحديدا امام البرلمان
اليوناني حيث توشك عمليات الفرز في
الانتخابات التشريعيه على الانتهاء
ويتنافس فيها رئيس الوزراء المحافظ ميتسو
تاكيس مع سلفه اليسري سيبراس وقد المح
رئيس الوزراء لاحتمال المرور الى جوله
ثانيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
توتر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه على وقع
اقتحامات وتصعيد وعمليه دهس بن كثير يقتحم
باحات المسجد الاقصى ويقول نحن اصحاب
القدس نتنياهو يجتمع بحكومته في نفق اسفل
المسجد الاقصى ويتحدث عن معركه توحيد
القدس وبعد ساعات من تصعيد الاحتلال اصابه
جندي اسرائيلي في عمليه دهس في حواره
بنابلس
قبل هجوم اوكرانيا مضاد تعد له كياف منذ
اشهر زيلينسكي يحصل على دعم ومساعدات
عسكريه في قمه السبع بهيروشيما تعهد
امريكي بتسليم كياف ذخيره ومدفعيه ومدرعات
جديده بايدن يقول ان كيف قدمت لواشنطن
تاكيدا قاطعا ان طائرات اف 16 لن تهاجم
الاراضي الروسيه
ينفي وضع قيود على استهداف شبه جزيره
القرد
قبل يوم من بدء وقف لاطلاق النار في
السودان يتضمن للمره الاولى اليه مراقبه
معارك عنيفه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
في ام درمان والمعارك تتواصل في الخرطوم
وهدوء بعد اشتباكات اوقعت 18 قتيلا
قبل عشره ايام من سيناريو تخلف الحكومه
الامريكيه عن سداد ديونها للمره الاولى في
التاريخ استئناف المفاوضات الليله بحثا عن
مخرج من ازمه سقف الدين العام رئيس مجلس
النواب يتمسك بمطالب خفض الانفاق قبل اي
اتفاق وبايدن يقول انه لن يقبل بصفقه
بشروط الجمهوريين ويلوح باللجوء الى اليه
دستوريه لتجاوز الكونترس
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اجتماع حكومه نتنياهو في
نفق اسفل الحائط الغربي او حائط البراق
بالمجد الاقصى قال نتنياهو في مستهل
الاجتماع ان جهود توحيد القدس لم تنتهي
وطرت واصدقائي مرارا وتكرارا الى سط
الضغوط الدوليه التي مارسها اولئك الذين
سيقسمون القدس مره اخرى هذه الخطوه تزامنت
مع اقتحام وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
اعتماد باحات المسجد الاقصى صباح اليوم
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم ما
هي ابعاد خطوه الحكومه الاسرائيليه وحديث
نتنياهو عن توحيد القدس جاءت النتائج على
النحو التالي ستون في المئه قالوا انه
استفزاز من فلسطينيين واسطه توترا يخيم
على الضفه اما اربعون في المئه فراوا انها
ارضاء المعارضه الاسرائيليه الغاضبه من
اجراءاته
وتعديلاته القضائيه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا في ملف خاص
كاميرا الجزيره ترصد الوضع القانوني
للاجئين زهيه في اندونيسيا
[موسيقى]
اصيب جندي اسرائيلي بجروح اثرى عمليه دهس
استهدفت مجموعه من الجنود في بلده حواره
جنوبي نابلس وافادت مراسله الجزيره بان
جيش الاحتلال اغلق شارع بلده حوار
الرئيسيه واغلاق المحله التجاريه ونصب عده
حواجز في محيط المنطقه للبحث عن منفذي
عمليه الدهس
وجاءت هذه العمليه بعد ساعات من اقتحام
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيليه اعتماد
بنكفير المسجد الاقصى مع عشرات المستوطنين
وهو الاقتحام الثاني له بصفته وزيرا في
الحكومه وقال بن كفار اثناء اقتحامه
الاقصى ان جبل الهيكل في اشاره للحرم
القدسي الشريف سيبقى تحت سياده
الاسرائيليه الى الابد حسب تعبيره
في الاثناء عقدت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
جلستها الاسبوعيه داخل نفق اسفل المسجد
الاقصى في خطوه لافته وقال رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو ان اسرائيل وحدت مدينه
القدس بعد الحرب قبل 56 عاما لكن المعركه
التي يخوضها لتوحيد القدس والتصدي للضغوط
الغربيه مستمره
تقع قضيه المسجد الاقصى ومدينه القدس في
قلب الصراع الفلسطينيه الاسرائيلي لكن
قضيه المسجد الاقصى تتجاوز كونها شانا
فلسطينيا بل هي قضيه اسلاميه بالدرجه
الاولى ويكفي ان اول منظمه اسلاميه جامعه
هي منظمه المؤتمر الاسلامي قد نشات كردي
فعلا لحرق المسجد الاقصى عام 69 ومع تصاعد
السياسات الاسرائيليه اليمينيه المتطرفه
حيال للمسجد الاقصى تزداد التحديات التي
تواجه الفلسطينيين والعالم الاسلامي على
حد سواء ولم يكن اجتماع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في نفق تحت المسجد الاقصى الا
بيانا صارخا عن هذه التحديات المتكاثفه
تقرير فوزي بشرح
لم تكد ما اطلقت عليه اسرائيل مسيره
الاعلام المحتفيه بضم مدينه القدس في حرب
عام 67 لم تكت تطوي اعلامها حتى جاءت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بفعل لا يقل استفزاز
وتحديا ليس للفلسطينيين وحدهم بل للعالم
العربي والاسلامي كليهما فما بدا
اسرائيليا صهيونيا يمينيا متشددا صار يتخذ
شكلا مؤسسيا تعبر عنه السياسه الاسرائيليه
الرسميه فهذه الحكومه التي يقودها بنيامين
نتنياهو والتي توصف بانها الاكثر يمينيه
في تاريخ اسرائيل تعقد اجتماعها في نفق
تحت حائط البراق الملاصق للمسجد الاقصى
حيث تقوم شبكه من الانفاق تضم 57 نفقا تحت
المسجد الاقصى
نتنياهو الذي يبدو منتشيا بهذه الموجه
اليمينيه قال ان المعركه لا تزال مستمره
من اجل توحيد القدس وقد اعتبدت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في اجتماعها زياده مبلغ 17
مليون دولار لميزانيه حفر الانفاق
والتنقيب عن الاثار والاثار هي ما تلح
اسرائيل في طلبه لتعزيز مقولاتها السياسيه
في القدس بحفريات تبحث عن هيكل سليمان
لاعاده بناء التصور للدوله اليهوديه
المقدسه من فسيفساء التاريخ اليهودي وهو
مسعا لم يثمر شيئا حتى الان فلم تبقى الا
القوه لفرض المقولات التلميذيه على نحو ما
يفعل
وزير الامن الداخلي الاسرائيلي واضطراد
علو نبره الخطاب الصهيوني دينيا كان او
قوميا يجد تعبيراته العمليه على الارض من
خلال اقتحامات المتطرفين لباحات المسجد
الاقصى ينخرط في ذلك نواب في الكنيست
ووزراء في الحكومه في مقدمتهم
ومشهد اليوم يقول ان التطرف الاسرائيليه
اصبح سلوكا رسميا يقف وراءه اليمين الديني
المتصاعد تيار حتى صار نيل رضاه بعضا من
وسائل التكسب السياسي كما يفعل رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو الذي قال ان بقاء
ائتلافه الحكومي وهو ائتلاف مستند الى
غلاه المتطرفين قال انه ضروري لتحقيق
توحيد القدس وامن اسرائيل
ورغم صمود الشعب الفلسطيني في صراعه
المتطاول ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وتضحياته
حربا بعد حرب وقتلا بعد قتل واعتقالا
وسجنا بعد اعتقال وسدي فان الصراع مع
اسرائيل على القدس ليس شانا فلسطينيا فقط
بل هو اسلامي بالدرجه الاولى كذلك
في زمان غير هذا الزمان كان حرق المسجد
الاقصى في عام 69 كافيا لايغاظ العالم
الاسلامي من سباته فخرجت منظمه المؤتمر
الاسلامي في العام نفسه تعبيرا عن الحاجه
الى موقف اسلامي موحد في وجه التحديات
الوجوديه
ثم دار الزمان دورته وارتقت قبضه العالم
الاسلامي على مقود التاريخ حتى توشك ان
تخرج من متنه فالتحدي الذي يواجه منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي المتحوره من منظمه
المؤتمر الاسلامي يبدو اشد خطرا من ذي قبل
فيما يتصل بالقدس والمسجد الاقصى انه
التحدي الذي يواجه المملكه المغربيه
بوصفها رئيسه للجنه القدس ويواجه المملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه بوصفها القيمه على
الاثار والمقدسات الاسلاميه والمسيحيه في
القدس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من يقسم معهم على الحد الادنى من المصحف
يتساءل الفلسطينيون فالاقصى قضيه لا تترك
لاحد في العالم العربي والاسلامي من
خيارات شتى فاما لزومها بما يستوجب النزول
واما لحاق بالقول النفق
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من رام الله الدكتور محمد
المصري رئيس المركز الفلسطيني للبحوث
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن نيوجيرسي
ريتشارد غوتستين المبعوث الخاص السابق
للرئيس كلينتون الى مفاوضات السلام بالشرق
الاوسط دكتور محمد ابدا معك اجتماع حكومه
نتنياهو اسفل المسجد الاقصى تزامن مع
اقتحام او تسلل هكذا هي حاله من كثير الى
المسجد الاقصى بدايه مدى وافع نتنياهو
لاجراء هذا الاجتماع في هذا المكان وما
الرسائل من هذه التحركات
مساء الخير لك سيدتي واريد البدء بالقول
بانه بن جفير دخل الى المسجد الاقصى اكثر
من مره قبل ذلك ولكن بهذا اليوم دخل
متسللا ودون اعلانا مسبق مع مجموعه من
حراسه وكتله من المستثمرين كما فعلنا
تنياهو نعم نعم
وبنفس الوقت ذهبنا نتنياهو بحكومه وايضا
متسلله بدون اعلان مسبق اسفل يعني حائط
البراق لكي اركز على قضايا محدده بالرب ان
هو لا يستطيع ان يكسر مشروعيه في وجوده
بالقدس اولا كان يريد ان يلم الشظايا
حكومه التي مختلفه حول موازنتها وهناك
خلافات داخليه جدا كبيره جدا الجانب الاخر
كان هناك قبل يومين يعني مؤتمر جده والذي
اغاظنا الثانيه وحكومه حينما تصدرت القضيه
الفلسطينيه الى جدول اعمال المؤتمر وكان
كل المتحدثين دون استثناء يشيد بالقضيه
الفلسطيني ووضعوها في المقدمه الجانب
الاخر ونحن راينا يوم الخميس الماضي كيف
هناك مسيره الاعلام الذي عمل جهدا نتنياهو
مستوطنين من اجل ان تكون في باب العمود
ومن ثم تستخترق يعني باتجاه المسجد الاقصى
ذهبت المسيره باعلامها وبقيت يعني بائعه
الفجل وبائع القهوه وبائع الكعك الاصفر في
القدس اسملاق القدس موجودين في القدس وليس
للتنميه هو مستوطنيه لكن اذا كان رغب
نتنياهو ان يؤكد لحكومته وما زال متمسكا
لكي يكسب مزيدا من الاصوات في اوساط
مستوطنيه بالتحديد على حساب الموضوع
الفلسطيني الرئيسي والموضوع العربي
والاسلامي نحن نقول كفلسطينيين باقيين
موجودين في هذا المكان ومستعدي للدفاع عن
مد من الاقصى ولكن هذه قضيه اسلاميه عربيه
بالدرجه كما كان في التقرير قبل قليل وهذه
مسؤوليه كل المسلمين في العالم وانا اذكر
بانه كمان درجه
هي استماله الاحزاب اليمنيه المتطرفه في
اسرائيل الهدف من هذا الاجتماع ولكن
نتنياهو تحدث عن ان معركه توحيد القدس
مستمره ونحن نتحدث عن ميزانيه تم رفعها من
اجل
استخدام المزيد من الشباب الاسرائيلي
للسكن في القدس وهي خطه على ثلاث سنوات
نعم هذا الفرق ما بين ما يقوم في دوله
الاحتلال نحن نحن في العرب والمسلمين
والفلسطينيين نتنياهو يتحدث ويدفع
بالارقام الماليه والضغط على
التهجيرهم وترحيلهم من القدس لكن
بالجانبنا هناك مؤتمر جده قبل يومين تحدث
عن القدس كثيرا ولكن نريد من هذا الجدول
البيان او جدول الاعلان الذي صدر في جده
ان يتحول الى سياسات فعليه على الارض لدعم
المقدسيين ودعم السلطه الوطنيه والشعب
الفلسطيني من اجل تمكينهم في مواجهه هذه
الهجمه الاستيطانيه الكبيره نحن يشن علينا
حربا كامله على مقدساتنا وبيوتنا واثارنا
وعائلاتنا وارضنا ولذلك نقول المعركه ليس
معركه الفلسطينيين وحدهم لعام 69 كما ذكر
التقرير حينما يعني حرق منظر الى المسجد
الاقصى
لميرف في هذه الليله ولكن اصبح الثاني يوم
لم يحرك اي مسلما ساكنا باستثناء تشكيل او
يعني ايجاد اللي هو بسموه المؤتمر
الاسلامي والذي لم يقدم الكثير ونعم هناك
شركاء في موضوع القدس يعني لجنه القدس
برئاسه رئيس البنك المغربي والوصايه
الاردنيه والسياده الفلسطينيه ولكن هذا
غير كافي هناك هجمه كبيره على الكل العربي
والمسلامي نسمع من السيد ريتشارد سيد
ريتشارد لطالما دعت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى تثبيت الوضع القائم ووقف
الاستفزازات ولكن ما هي فاعله تجاه
الخطوات التي تتخذها الحكومه الاسرائيليه
شكلا ومضمونا
ليس لدي اي شاك من ان
ان
ان الولايات المتحده ومسؤولين من اعلى
المستويات سيقومون بالتواصل مع السيد
نتنياهو تجاه ما يقوم به وهذا الاستفزاز
الذي لا يساعد باي شكل من الاشكال في
تحقيق فكره السلام من الواضح انه من
البدايه انه كان
يحاول ان يرضي اليمين في احزاب اليمين
المتطرف ولا هذه وهذا ما يشكله حكومته هو
ايضا امنيته تركز على مساليه تدعم
الاسرائيليين الارثوذكسيين المتشددين
الذين
يركزون على
اجندتهم الخاصه وهذه الزياره الى
سؤالي كان عن الجانب الامريكي وتحركات
الجانب الامريكي تتحدث عن تواصل يعني هل
التواصل كاف في هذه الحاله حيث يتحدث
نتنياهو عن توحيد القدس وهو ما يخالف كل
القرارات الدوليه والشرعيه الدوليه
في حقيقه الامر لم يقبل الطرفان شرعيه
وجود الاخر هذا وهذا الامر ليس مفيدا ليس
الامر مفاجئا لنا وليس خبرا طارئا ان
حكومه نتنياهو التي تفضل ان لا يكون هناك
دوله فلسطينيه كما ان الامر ليس مفاجئ ان
هنالك قاده فلسطينيين يتمنون ان اسرائيل
تختفي لذلك لا اعتقد علينا ان نرى هذا
الامر على انه امر مفاجئ امر مؤسف هو نعم
لكن مره اخرى هو ليس بالامر الجديد
الى حد الان لم اسمع منك رد على سؤالي
فيما يتعلق بتحركات الجانب الامريكي هل
ستكتفي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بالتواصل
من الواضح ان هنالك الكثير من الطرق التي
تتمكن فيها الولايات المتحده ربما ان تقوم
بالتاثير في تعاملاتها مع الكثير من الدول
من ضمنها اسرائيل الاقتراح هو ربما قد
يكون هل ستقوم ربما الولايات المتحده ان
توقف مساعدتها الى اسرائيل او تقوم باتخاذ
خطوات اضافيه انا اشك في حصول هذا الامر
ولن او تفاجا لانه في مرحله ما وبوجود
المستوطنات والاجراءات الاستفزازيه فان
الولايات المتحده عليها ان توصل رساله الى
اسرائيل مفادها انها قد تجاوزت الحد هل
اعتقد ان هذا الامر سيحدث قريبا لك كلا
لكن اعتقد ان هنالك رسائل صارمه حازمه
سيتم ايصالها الى اسرائيل وهنالك تهديد
ربما مبطن بان اسرائيل عليها ان لا تغير
من الوضع الحالي وعليها ان تغير هذه
السياسه التي تتبعها
المبعوث الخاص السابق للرئيس كلينتون الى
مفاوضه السلام بالشرق الاوسط والشكر موصول
الى الدكتور محمد المصري رئيس المركز
الفلسطيني للبحوث والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في مؤتمر
صحفي عقده في ختام مشاركته في قمه السبع
انه وافق على تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
على طائرات اف 16
واوضح مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
ان واشنطن لن تزود اكياف بمقاتلات اف 16
من مخزونها القومي بل عبر طرف ثالث وضعف
ان بلاده لن تمكن اوكرانيا من استخدام
مساعدات الغرب العسكريه لضرب روسيا داخل
حدودها
من علي تتمتع بالافضليه تعلم جيوش ان
قدراتها الناريه الجويه تقطع بها عاده وقت
الحرب نصف المسافه نحو النصر اوكرانيا
فهمت ذلك مبكرا ليس من شك في ان ما تلقته
من اسلحه غربيه حتى الان له كفاءته في
الميدان غير ان التبلور هجومها المضاد على
القوات الروسيه سيحوجها لاسلحه اكثر تطورا
وفاعليه
وتلك حاجه تزداد مع اداء الحربي روسي اخرج
ضخمه من نطاق سيطرتها بحسب تاكيدات موسكو
لا يسلم الرئيس الاوكراني بحسم الروس اطول
معارك حربهم على بلاده ولعله مطمئن بعد
اقرار حزمه جديده من المساعدات العسكريه
من واشنطن تصل قيمتها الى
375 مليون دولار
لكن اكثر ما يسعد زيلينسكي هو تاكد
حصولكييف في وقت ما على مقاتلات اف 16
الامريكيه
خلال اجتماعي مع الرئيس زلينسكي وكبار
الموظفين اثر ختام اجتماعات قمه الدول
السبع قلت ان الولايات المتحده وشركائها
سيبداون في تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
على الجيل الرابع من المقاتلات ومن بينها
طائرات اف 16 من اجل تعزيز قدره سلاح الجو
الاوكراني وكجزء من التزام طويل الاجل
لمساعده اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن نفسها
يامل الاوكرانيون في ان الطائرات الاف سته
عشر ستغير مسار المعارك لمصلحتهم
مقاتله الصقر المهاجم كما تسمى ايضا
يستخدمها نحو 28 جيجا عبر العالم يبلغ وزن
الواحده منها ثمانيه الاف وسته مئه
كيلوغرام
وبمقدورها ان تحمل خمسه الاف كلغ من
الاسلحه والذخائر اما سرعتها القصوى في
2120 كيلو مترا في الساعه متى ستحصل كييف
على هذه المقاتلات كيف ولايه غايه يقول
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
ان الرئيس بايدن لم يتخذ قرارا بشان تقديم
تلك الطائرات من مخزونات الولايات المتحده
وان الحديث هو على ان يقدمها طرف ثالث
لاوكرانيا
اما عن قيود استخدام الاسلحه الامريكيه في
اوكرانيا فيوضح السولفان انها تقتصر على
عدم استخدامها داخل حدود روسيا وبالتالي
فبمقدور اوكرانيا ضرب الجيش الروسي داخل
حدودها المعترف بها وشبه جزيره القرم جزء
منها قد يعطي ذلك لمحه عن نطاق هجوم
اوكرانيا المضاد المنتظر لكنه يكشف عن حرص
حلفاء كييف في عمومهم على عدم خروج الامور
عن السيطره دون استباق الاحداث يجري
التركيز الان على تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على استخدام الجيل الاحدث من
المقاتلات الغربيه
بريطانيا التي تبدا العمليه على الارجح
خلال هذا الصيف توافقت مع دول غربيه على
تزويد كييف بالقدره الجويه القتاليه التي
تحتاجها
وعدت زيلينسكي ايضا بتسليم جيشه صواريخ
ستورم شادو بعيده المدى
وتلك بحسب خبراء عسكريين ستمثل تحديات
جديده صعبه للدفاعات الروسيه
في المقابل لا اتهم وزير الخارجات الروسيه
الدول الغربيه بمحاوله هزيمه بلاده
والقضاء عليها كمنافس جيوسياسي حسب تعبيره
اضاف ان الغرب حدد مهمته بالقضاء على
روسيا كمنافس
وهو ما تمثل في القرارات التي اتخذت في
قمه هيروشيما والتي تهدف الى الردع
المزدوج لروسيا والصين حسب تعبيره
لقد حددوا المهمه بصوت عال وبشكل هزيمه
روسيا في ساحه المعركه ولا يتم التوقف عند
هذا الحد بل القضاء عليها كمنافس جيوسياسي
وبطبيعه الحال سيتم ردع اي بلد اخر يدعي
نوعا من الاستقلاليه في النظام العالمي
انظروا الى القرارات التي يجري اتخاذها في
قمه مجموعه السبع الكبار في هيروشيما
والتي تهدف الى الرضع المزدوج لروسيا
والصين لروسيا العديد من الحلفاء نحن لا
نشجع العداء تجاه اي كان لكننا مضطرون
الرد بحزم على الحرب المعلنه ضدنا
معنى من جناف العقيد الكساندرا فور ترافرس
رئيسه تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
اهلا بك سيد الكسندر سيد الكسندر الرئيس
الامريكي يشير الى الاف سته عشر قائلا
يمكن ان تحدث فرقا كبيرا من حيث القدره
على التعامل مع ما هو اتن ما الذي هو اتن
اعتقد ان هنالك طرق عديده بامكانها ان
نقرا في هذه في هذا التصريح هنالك امور
على المدى القصير لان الاوكرانيا بدات
تستنضف كل انظمه الدفاع الجوي المتوفره
لديها اذا عدا المدى القريب فان هذه
الطائره ستتمكن من حمايه السكان والبنى
التحتيه المهمه في المدى المدن الاوكرانيه
ضد القصف وضد صواريخ كروز بالتاكيد هنالك
طريقه ثانيه لقراءه هذا التصريح وهو على
المدى الطويل وما الامكانيات الفريده التي
والجديده التي بامكاني ان توفرها هذه
الطائرات للجيش الاوكراني في شني دفاعاته
المضاده وايضا هنالك امور اضافيه اخرى ان
اوكرانيا لن تستنفذ جنودها او ذخيرتها
مثلا او المعدات الثقيله ولكن روسيا ربما
ستستنفذ هذه ما تملكه من الدخائر ومن
اشخاص كفوئين قبل اوكرانيا من خلال ما
قاله سولفان هل يمكن ان نحدد نطاق الهجوم
المضاد التي
تتحدث عنه اوكرانيا منذ فتره
او ما عرف بهجوم الربيع
لا نعرف لحد الان لان الاوكرانيين
استخدموا الكثير من معلومات غير صحيحه من
اجل التظليل على اعداء في مساله الهجمه
المضاده هنالك الكثير من الاحتمالات فيما
يتعلق بهذه الهجمه المضاده نعرف ان
الاوكرانيين الان
ركزوا حوالي تسع كتائب
مع الياتها وهذه معظم ربما معظم القوات
التي تم تحديدها من اجل شنه الهجمه
المضاده في بشار اغسطس عام 2021 وقد قال
الاوكرانيين لانهم يريدون ايضا كتائب تصل
الى 20 كتيبه مع الياتها من اجل شن هجمه
المضاده من الشامله وقد يهاجمه ربما في
وجهه واحده او وجهتين او ثلاثه اذا ما
توفرت لهم المعدات والافراد التي
يحتاجونها لكن هل
ترى على الموقف الغربي من جزيره القرم
كانت خارج المعادله حسب ما كان يبدو في
بدايه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا الان هل
يوافق الغرب على ان تستهدف اوكرانيا
الجانب الروسي في جزيره القرم
اعتقد انه لحد الان فان الاسلحه التي تم
ايصالها الى اوكرانيا مؤخرا كانت تم
تسليمها تحت شرط على انها ستستخدم فقط في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن حسب علمي فان وحسب
القانون الدولي وكما
يخضع له اعتراف الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده ومجلس الامن فان القلم هي
جزء رسميا هي جزء من اوكرانيا شكرا لك
العقيد الكسندر
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء بمزيد
من التفاصيل على مقاتلات اف 16
ونسال ضيف الحصاد عن اهميتها في جبهات
القتال في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث اعلن طرف نزاع التزامهما
بالهدنه المرتقبه بدءا من الغده وفقا
لاتفاق جده الجديد لوقف اطلاق النار اما
على الارض فقد دارت معارك عنيفه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في اندرمان
وسجلت غارات على مواقع مختلفه بالخرطوم
بينما اخيا ما هدوء حذر فينيالا بعد معارك
داميه اوقعت 18 قتيلا ذكر الجيش السوداني
انه قصف اهدافا لقوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق كافوري والحج يوسف وشارع الستين
شرقي العاصمه الخرطومه وبحسب مراسل
الجزيره فقد اطلقت قوات الدعم السريع
مضادات الطائرات في محاوله للتصدي لغارات
طائرات الجيش
قال بيان سعودي امريكي ان اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان يدخل حيز التنفيذ الساعه
التاسعه 9:45 من صباح الاثنين بتوقيت
الخرطوم واضاف البيان ان الاتفاق ستدعمه
اليه مراقبه مدعومه دوليا من قبل السعوديه
والولايات المتحده وذلك للمره الاولى منذ
بدء المواجهات واتضمن الاتفاق ان طرفي
النزاع في السودان التزم بايصال وتوزيع
المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه كما التزمها بسحب القوات من
المستشفيات والمرافق العامه الاساسيه
انضموا الينا هنا من الاستوديو الدكتور
مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني دكتور مزمل ابدا معك من اتفاق
جده الجديد ساعات على دخول هذه الهدنه
بحيز التنفيذ ما فرص نجاح هذه الهدنه
ياتي هذا الاتفاق في عقاب ما اصطلح على
تسميته اعلان جده الذي وقع بين الطرفين
ايضا بنفس الرعايه وبواساطه سعوديه
امريكيه لكنه لم يتحول الى واقع على الارض
لم يتم الالتزام به مطلقا وظلت الاتهامات
تتقاضب بين الطرفين كل طرفهم الاخر
بعدم الالتزام نتحدث عن اليه مراقبه هذه
في حد ذاتها معضله اذا لم يتم الاعلان عن
هذه الاليه وتفاصيلها الحديث تم عن اليه
مكونه من اثني عشر شخصا ثلاثه من الجيش
السوداني ثلاثه من قوات الدعم السريع
ثلاثه من الجانب السعودي وثلاثه من الجانب
الامريكي لكن لم يتم توضيح الاليه التي
سيتم بها تنفيذ هذه الاليه
اننا نتحدث عن عاصمه
بمساحه دوله المواجهات في الخرطوم تدور في
جنوب الخرطوم من منطقه الباقر جنوبا وحتى
القصر الجمهوري شمالا وفي بحر تدور من
حدود
وبراق على النيل وحتى منطقه الجيلي في شرق
النيل تدور من منطقه العلفون وحتى منطقه
المصفاه وبعدها في ام درمان ايضا تغطي
المعارك كلها
مناطق ام درمان تقريبا هذه مساحات شاسعه
جدا تنتشر فيها قوات الدعم السريع وتدور
فيها معارك عنيفه مع الجيش لا احد يدري
كيف سيتم مراقبه كل هذه المناطق على
اعتبار ان المعارك تدور كل حين كل على راس
كل ساعه تدور معركه في منطقه من مناطق
الخرطوم لكن هناك ما يرى بان تغييرات ولو
طفيفه طراءت على الارض ربما قد تؤدي الى
نجاح هذه الهدنه هل تشارك
ما حدث في السابق لا يدفع الى التفاؤل على
اعتبار ان اعلان جده نص على الزام
الطرفين بالابتعاد عن المستشفيات الخروج
من المدارس ومن الجامعات
المدنيه
ومعلوم بالضروره ان هذه المناطق اضطرت
قوات الدعم السريع الى الدخول اليها
واحتلتها
وحاول الجيش ان يخرجها منها ولكن بالطبع
لا تستطيع ان تقصف مستشفى لا تستطيع ان
تقصف منازل مدنيين هذه اتهامات تعرضت وهذا
الدعم السريع التي في رايي
وجدت نفسها في معضله كبيره عقب اقدام
الجيش على قصف كل مقرها حول العاصمه في في
الخرطوم
اعلان جده او المرحله الجديده من اعلان
جده مع تعينات جديده في الداخل
هل من علاقه بين الجانبين بكل تاكيد هذه
القرارات التي اتخذها رئيس مجلس السياده
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح عمرو البرهان وهو
بالطبع قائد الجيش
كان لها انعكاس على الميدان او كان
الميدان انعكاز عليها على الاصح لانها
اشارت الى ان الجيش التقط انفاسه الضغط خف
عليه ان
قواته في الميدان حققت تقدمهم ملحوظا ان
قوات الدعم السريعه لم تعد تشكل خطرا عليه
وبالتالي انصرف رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد
الجيش الى محاوله اعاده ترتيب اوراق
الدوله اعفى عدد من السفراء ايضا عين
نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده اتخذ عدد من
القرارات التي من شانها ان تحسن تحسن من
حياه مدنيين في الخرطوم المسمى لابو
القاسم الكاتب المحلل السياسي السوداني
شكرا لك
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان على
الجمهوريين ان يعرفوا انه لن يتم انجازه
اي صفقه بين الحزبين وفقا لشروطهم فقط
وذلك في اشاره للمفاوضات الجاريه بشان رفع
سقف الدين العامه واضف بايدن في تغريده
على حسابه لانه طرح خطه لتقليل الانفاق
باكثر نتريليون دولار وان على الجمهوريين
ان يتحركوا من جانبهم واشدد الرئيس
الامريكي في تغريده ثانيه بانه لا يوافق
على صفقه تحمي شركات النفط الكبرى بينما
تهدد الرعايه الصحيه لواحد وعشرين مليون
امريكي ولا يوافق على صفقه تحمل غشاشين
والمتهربين الاثرياء من الضرائب بينما
تهدد المساعدات الغذائيه لمليون امريكي
بحسب تعبيره
هذا وقالت وسائل اعلام امريكيه ان الرئيس
جو بايدن تحدث هاتفيا مع رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي كيفن ماكارتي واتفق معه على ان
يجتمع مفاوضوا الطرفين مساء اليوم
بالتوقيت المحلي كما ان بايدن سيلتقي
ماكارتي غدا في البيت الابيض هذا وكان
مكارتي قد اتهمت ديمقراطيين بالرغبه في
زياده الانفاق اكثر من المستويات المتوقعه
لهذا العام واشدد على ان الجمهوريين
يرفضون ذلك بسبب اتساع حجم العجز في
الموازنه المقدر حاليا بتريليون و500
مليار دولار
رفض رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن تحميل
اداره بايدن الجمهوريين مسؤوليه عدم
التواصل الاتفاق بشان رفع سقف الدين العام
حتى الان وقال مكارتي في حديث لشبكه فوكس
نيوز ان العرض الاخير الذي قدم للرئيس
مبني على اسس منطقيه ولا يتضمن مطالب
متطرفه او قاسيه كما ادعى الرئيس بحسب
وصفه
تقترح ميزانيه الرئيس انفاق اموال اكثر
مما انفقناه في ذروه الوباء لا يمكننا
الاستمرار في الاقتراض من الصين والاعتماد
عليها وخلق المزيد من التضخم لا اعتقد انه
من التطرف القول انه يجب ان ننفق اقل مما
انفقناه هذا العام لا اعتقد انه من التطرف
ايضا اننا نريد ان نكون قادرين على ضبط
المزيد من النفقات نحن لا نضع عراقيل امام
عمل الحكومه بل نسمح لها بالنمو بنسبه
واحد في المئه لذا فنعرض الذي قدمناه
للرئيس يستند الى افكار منطقيه ومسؤوله
ومعقوله
وحذرت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جانت من
تداعيات تخلف الولايات المتحده عن
التزامها برفع سقف الدين العام قائله ان
المساله ستضع البلاد امام خيارات صعبه
ستكون هناك خيارات صعبه يجب اتخاذها اذا
لم يرفع سقف الدين العام اود قوله ببساطه
ان لدى الولايات المتحده منذ عام
1789 تاريخا في الالتزام بسداد فواتيرها
في الوقت المحدد هذا ما يريد العالم ان
يراه باعتبار ان سندات الخزانه الامريكيه
هي الاستثمار الاكثر امانا على ظهر هذا
الكوكب وعدم قدرتنا على تزيد التزاماتنا
ووضع غير مقبول لنا
تنضم الينا من واشنطن كلي فلاوس كبيره
الباحثين والمحرره السياسيه لشؤون الحكومه
في معهد كوينسي سيده كليب ما هي فرص
التوصل الى اتفاق بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين فيما يتعلق برفع سقف الدين
العام
كل ما استطعت قوله ان الامر سيكون صعبا
للغايه اخبار الطيبه ان واشنطن بوست وضع
نشرت تقريرا ان الطرفين قد توافق على ان
يعيدوا فتح المحادثات بينهما انا لدي
انطباع من ان بدايه في بدايه الاسبوع ربما
قد نارا فوضات جديده بين البيت الابيض
وبين الحزب الجمهوري
وافراد الحزب مشاكل هذا الامر ان كلا
الطرفين يرغبان بالانخراط في هذه المرحله
في مساله خفض الانفاق لكنهم لا يمكن ان
يتفقوا حول من اين ستاتي هذه انخفض
الانفاق هذه هذه كانت مشكله تاريخيه حيث
ان الجمب بين جمهورينا والديمقراطينا
كانوا دائما يختلفون عليها
الجمهوريه يريدون
انفاق اكثر على الدفاع مثلا وانفاق اقل
حول مساله البرامج المحليه لكن بالنسبه
الديمقراطينا فهم
متمسكون متمسكون برفضهم في القطع الانفاق
وتخفيض الانفاق على البرامج المحليه
وتقليل وهم يميلون الى تقليل الانفاق
الدفاعي هذه قرار انها مرارا وتكرارا وكان
هنالك اختلاف بينهما حتى اللحظه الاخيره
افضل شيء بامكاننا ان نامله هو انه ربما
سيتم للتواصل الى الاتفاق في قبل الاول من
يونيو لكن اذا لم يحصل ذلك قد يكون هنالك
تمديد بالتالي فان الدوله لا او البلد لا
يعجز عن تسديد ديونه يعني وزيره الخزانه
تتحدث عن خيارات صعبه ما هي هذه الخيارات
سيدك
الخيارات الصعبه هي
كميه الاستقطاعات في الميزانيه الحكوميه
الجمهوريه يريدون النمو يعود الى واحد
بالمئه هذا يعني الكثير من الاستقطاعات في
تخفيض الانفاق في البرامج المحليه والتي
ما يقترحونه هو مثلا برامج مثل خطه بايدن
لتقليل
الديون على مثلا قروض الطلبه وايضا يريدون
تخفيضا
لمساله البعض البرامج المحليه لانهم طرحوه
بعض المطالب حول العمال الذين يتلقون
الاعانات وهم يريدون ان يروا متطلبات
للعمل يريدون ان من الناس ان يعملوا قبل
ان يحصلوا على الاعانات ايضا الاعانات
المرتبطه بالجائحه يريدون توقفا لهذه
الامور هنالك امور قالت اداره بايدن انها
خطوط حمراء ليست مستعده ان تخفض من
الانفاق في هذا الامر لان هذا الامر يدعم
الطبقه العامله والطبقه الوسطى
سيده كليف لا هاوس كبيره الباحثين
والمحرره السياسيه لشؤون الحكومه في معهد
كوينسي شكرا لك
اظهرت نتائج فرزي اكثر من 90% من الاصوات
في الانتخابات التشريعيه اليونانيه تقدما
كبيرا لحزب الديمقراطيه الجديده اليميني
المحافظ بقياده رئيس الحكومه المنتهيه
ولايته كيرياكوس ميتسو تاكيس حيث حصل على
146 مقعدا من اصل 300 هي مقاعد البرلمان
وقال ميتسو تاكيس انه سيذهب الى جوله
ثانيه ولي يلجا الى التحالف مع حزب اخر
لتشكيل حكومه جديده واضاف ان اليونان
تحتاج الى حكومه تؤمن بالاصلاحات ولا يمكن
ان يحدث هذا مع حكومه هشه وفق تعبيره
وتاتي تصريحات ميتسو تاكيس رغم تصدر حزبه
للانتخابات وقد سجلت الانتخابات تراجعا
كبيرا لتيار اليسار وفي مقدمته تحالف
اليسار الرديكالي المسمى تحالف سيريزا
بقياده رئيس الحكومه
والذي حصل على 72 مقعدا
يوزع اللاجئون روهينغيا بعد وصولهم او
يوزعوا الى سواحل اقليم اتشل اندونيسيه
على مراكز لجوء متفرقه ويفضل الكثيرون
منهم البقاء في اندونيسيا ودول مجاوره لها
حتى يتم توطينهم في بلد ثالث عبر مفوضيه
اللاجئين والمنظمه العالميه للهجره وفي
ملف خاص بقضيه الروهينغا يرصد مراسلنا
صهيب جاسم في هذا التقرير الوضع القانونيه
للاجئين الروهنجه في اندونيسيا
بضع سنوات مضت على لجوء هذه العائلات
الروهنيه الى اندونيسيا وهم ينتظرون
توطينهم في بلدان تقبل اللاجئين وتمنحهم
جنسيتها حتى اطفالهم لم يحصلوا على حق
التعليم الى وقت قريب محمد يونس احد هؤلاء
يتحدث عن فراره من الاضطهاد في مينيمار
منذ تسع سنين واليوم يتطلع للاستقرار في
اي بلد يقبله
لو لم تقبلنا الولايات المتحده فلاجر الى
كندا او نيوزلندا او استراليا ولو كان ذلك
كله محالا فلنرجع الى ميانمار ولو تعذرت
هجرتنا الى اي مكان فانا اقبل الجنسيه
الاندونيسيه لو منحت له ورغم طول الانتظار
في اندونيسيا لمن يرغب في توطينه في بلد
ثالث وصعوبه التاقلم اقتصاديا والاقامه
قانونيا لمن يريد البقاء هنا فان سفن هجره
الرهينغا من من مارو بنغلاديش مستمره في
ابحارها نحو سواحل اقليم اتشيلين اندونيسي
فهذه من اخر السفن التي وصلت من بنغلاديش
عبر المحيط الهندي صغار وكبار رجال ونساء
تقطعت بهم السبل حتى وصلوا الى هنا وبحسب
المسؤولين الاندونيسيين لاستعاده لحقوق
الرهنجيا دون حل قضيتهم من جذورها
تسويه القضيه الرهنجيه لم تشهد تقدما ففي
الاشهر الاخيره الثلاثه استقبلت اندونيسيا
المئات منهم فلقد باتت تسويه هذه القضيه
اكثر صعوبه بسبب الاحوال في
لا تمنح اندونيسيا ودول اسيان المجاوره حق
اللجوء الدائم او الجنسيه للاجئين ولذلك
وحسب متابعين لشان الرهنجيا يفكر بعضهم
بالهجره مره اخرى الى بلدان مجاوره وفي
مقدمتها ماليزيا بحثا عن فرص عمل
من يصلون من الرومونديا الى ساحل اي دوله
يجب ان يعاملوا بكرامه فهم فارون من
الاباده الجماعيه ووضعهم في بورما يزداد
سوءا سجلنا منذ عام 2016 تزايدا في عدد من
يعتقلون دون هويات او وثائق وفي شهر
ديسمبر الماضي وحده سجن نحو 400 منهم
بينهم نساء واطفال
ويلاحظ في السفن الاخيره القادمه الى
اندونيسيا نسبه اطفال مرتفعه تزيد من
المسؤوليه الملقاه على المنظمات الانسانيه
المحليه التي تقول انها تقدم ما بوسعها
لاعانه القادمين الجدد
[موسيقى]
اقليم اتشي الاندونيسي
في سما المعركه ولا تتعلق الصعوبات بتسليم
مقاتلات اف 16 وحسب بل ايضا بتدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين عليها وهو ما قد
يستغرق شهورا بالنظر الى تعقيدات
تكنولوجيا الطائره
واللغه المقاتلات الامريكيه اف 16 هي من
مقاتلات الجيل الرابع وتعرف باسم الصقر
المقاتل وهي ذات مميزات عاليه وتستخدمها
جيوش 25 دوله عبر العالم ومن اهم خصائصها
انها مقاتله متعدده المهام ولديها القدره
على المناوره والطيران في جميع الظروف
الجويه وتبلغ سرعتها القصوى نحو 2500
كيلومتر في الساعه
وبامكان طائره 16 التحليق على ارتفاع اكثر
من 15 كيلومترا وهي مسافه تقطعها خلال
دقيقه واحده من الاقلاع وتمنح تلك
المواصفات الطائره ماذا يا كثيره
فهجوميا يمكنها اطلاق القذائف لمسافات
بعيده ما يجعلها قادره على ضرب مواقع
القياده والسيطره الروسيه والمواقع
اللوجستيه والقواعد في عمق اوكرانيا بما
في ذلك شبه جزيره القرم ومياه البحر
الاسود
ودفاعيا تستطيع افسته عشر اسقاط الطائرات
الروسيه المقاتله واسقاط صواريخ كروز التي
تستهدف البنيه التحتيه لاوكرانيا وهو ما
يعزز احتمال احداثها فرقا في مسار الحرب
طائره اف 16
تم تصنيعها للمره الاولى عام
1976 وهناك اليوم اكثر من ثلاثه الاف منها
في الخدمه العسكريه عبر العالم بما في ذلك
نحو الف طائره في القوات الجويه
والبحريه الامريكيه للمزيد ينضم الينا من
بيروت
العميد الياس حناء الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي عميد الياس تزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات اف 16 هل سيحدث فرقا في ارض
المعركه
اذا بالطبع لانه قد تكتمل المنظومه
الغربيه يعني من المدفعيه الى التدريب الى
التجهيز الى
المدرعات الى الدبابات الى الدفاعات
الجويه الحديثه اذا اكتملت الاف 16 هذا
الامر سيؤدي الى القول ان اسرع جيش انتقل
الى الحداثه في العالم خلال سنه ونيف هو
الجيش الاوكراني اليوم يبقى الاستعمال متى
كيفيه الاستعمال عدد الطائرات المده
المستلزمه وهل فعلا ستؤدي او ستساعد هذه
الطائرات الى هجوم المنتظر الياس يعني كم
تحتاج اوكرانيا من الطائرات هي تتحدث عن
اثنتي عشره طائره هل يمكن ان يؤدي ذلك الى
فرق حقيقي
هل هذا العدد كافن اولا انا
فدى انا اعتقد ان اوكرانيا طلبت 200 طائره
يعني كل كل سرب هي بين 15 و18 وال 24 حسب
التشكيله 200 طائره
سيتم التدريب ليس بالضرور ان يكون هناك
200 طائره جاهزه اليوم بالتدريج قد يتم
الانتقال الى هذا العدد لماذا لانه عندما
نتحدث عن الهيمنه الجويه او السيطره
الجويه فوق اوكرانيا لدى روسيه ما يقارب
900 طائره و200 ونيف ايضا من القذفات
الاستراتيجيه فاذا يجب ان يكون هناك بالحد
الادنى توازن معين 12 طائره هذا امر بسيط
جدا جدا هي سرب او حتى اقل من سرب كم
يحتاج التدريب على هذه الطائرات من قبل
الطيارين الاوكرانيين
كم من الوقت
لتدريبها السؤال كم من الوقت لتدريب الوقت
يستلزم
اولا المشكله الاوكرانيه انه سيسحب
طيارون لهم خبره يقاتلون اليوم على الساحه
الاوكرانيه لتدريبهم هي بين الاربعه اشهر
وسته اشهر هذا للطيار يجب ان اتحدث ايضا
عن التعهد المنتنس ايضا يجب ان نتحدث عن
الفنيين يجب ان نتحدث عن الذخيره وكيفيه
ادخال هذه المنظومه من الطائرات في
المعركه القادمه هل ستكون هذه الطائرات
للهجوم المرتقب فاذا يجب ان ننتظر ام هي
لمرحله لاحقه من حاله اوكرانيا للدفاع عن
نفسها ضد الروسيه في مرحله لاحقه شكرا لك
العميد الياس حناء الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي
هي قصه جديده من قصصي نجاح في مواجهات
التحديات هاري بودا مقارن جندي نبالي سابق
تعرض لبدر ساقي الى ما فوق الركبتين بعدما
داس على لغم يدوي الصنع خلال خدمته في
افغانستان سنه 2010 في اطار كتيبه الجنود
ناباليين في صفوف الجيش البريطاني اليوم
بات مجار اول شخص مبتور الساقين الى مفوق
الركبتين ينجح في تسلق جبل افرست الذي
يبلغ ارتفاعه
8,849 مترا وسبقا لمجاري الذي جهز باطراف
اصطناعيه ان تسلق قمما عده بينها جبل
توبكال في المغرب
في اوروبا هي قصه اصرار وعزيمه لخصها
مجاري في وقت سابق بالقول بامكاننا
في حياتنا مع وقتنا ووضعنا كل شيء ممكن لا
تكون هناك اي حدود بل تصبح السماء هي
الحدود عندما تهن عزيمه اي منه في مواجهات
التحديات علينا ان نتذكر هذه العباره
السماء هي الحدود
ونختم بهذا الخبر فبعد ان احالتهم النيابه
العامه الى محاكم الجنائيه بتهمه قياده
جماعه ارهابيه قضت محكمه امن الدوله
العليا في مصر بالسجن المؤبد في حق
الاعلامي المصري حمزه زويبع وثلاثه عشر
اخرين كما حكمت على ثلاثه اخرين بالسجن
المشدد لمده 15 عاما بعد اتهامهم بالتحريض
ضد مؤسسات الدوله ونشر اخبار كاتبه
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد شكرا على حسن
المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]